hey let's face it at the top of the show
I was a little bit cranky about being
stuck inside but I shouldn't be I've
mentioned this before there's a whole
world of wonder we just look outside our
windows into our own backyards it's true
grab some binoculars it's amazing what
you'll see oh man check it out it's the
common northern fringe what a beautiful
call oh and here's the less common
scatting Finch keep depth cooped-up the
D ba doop da de beep now that the
weather is warmer a lot of birds are
making their way back to their northern
habitats one now oh god no it's a herd
of lemmings mindlessly following their
leader off a cliff oh no these have been
all over the news
it's the murder wasp and of course
there's the suspected of murder wasp
doing what I'm doing if it hadn't been
for oh oh here's something it's very
common in nature it's an animal frozen
in place hoping she won't be noticed by
predators we're getting there's a beetle
and there's a white snake
and there's a flock of seagulls what'd
you think I was gonna do show the band a
flock of seagulls how unoriginal and
lame would that be what do you want from
us we're doing what we can